[Music]
my favorite movies make me excited to
live and that's what Amsterdam is and
that's what we work to make it due to
the talent and Brilliance of the actors
and their willingness to collaborate
okay ready camera Parker are ready and
action Christian Bale with someone I
spoke to for years about these roles we
would meet regularly for breakfast at a
diner we would just keep talking about
it when you prep for that long oh man
it's just in your bones so it's uh
really really satisfying experience I
started talking to David about the
character years ago his process is
totally unique the character and the
story and everything just evolves all
I'm saying is as long as already gone up
by the time we finished our dialogue he
insisted upon you understanding that
it's wide open this world and the
possibilities are endless with David he
does movies that are very personal and
special and have their own energy you
sang a song you should remember the song
I'd like you to sing it now then I'll
know it's you did you ever see your
dreams
oh no that's that's not it he's got like
all these ideas sort of satellites going
around what's up he loves his characters
in his words but if he had to choose he
I think he chooses the act of
interpretation of his words and of the
story so pull him in tight yeah
he allows his actors a certain
authorship of the character he made me
feel like I could walk on fire and walk
through walls David's really interested
in allowing our Humanity to come through
he wants you to show up and be alive
that all starts with David it's an
energy that is infectious he's magical
go back to everybody laughing and then
get them laughing
all right here we go pictures up the
experience of making this movie is like
the movie really charming and magical
propulsive and really fun this is a
movie in the old-fashioned sense and in
the new fashion sense it's bold it's
epic and it's visually stunning and it's
all enveloping it's an experience to
answer them
[Music]